yunus et squeeze aujourd'hui on se
trouve sur la mise à jour 2 the forest
l'alphabet 0.07 c'est parti est sortie
hier et il ya pas mal de nouveautés donc
je trouvais ça intéressant de faire des
vidéos dessus on va notamment se prendre
pour tarzan va prendre notre fameuse h
et ouvrir quelques balises ya nouveautés
que j'ai toujours voulu faire c'est aux
normands peut attraper des lapins pour
les mettre dans la cage à lapins alors
comment ça se passe lui il a l'air un
peu drogués cela pas carrément à deux à
l'heure rien au regard des ondes tient
pas le coup comme ça à temps vers est
carrément une peluche ques plus du tout
à lapins ouais mais là j'ai pas encore
fait la cage donc attend un retour dans
la nature petit lapin bretons mais
[ __ ] il est mort non il dort juste là
bas non mort permet d'entrer du on tue à
la pause sans même le vouloir quoi on va
enlever quelques valises histoire
d'avoir voilà quelques barres
chocolatées ou léon les aime tant puis
elle nous dépanne temps et j'ai fait
attrapé au passage jeta grave au passage
manga ouai ouai c'est fin c'est horrible
un élève à petit lapin mais non mais en
plus à la pause par terre comme ça mais
en fait il est décédé quoi bon ben on
aura de la bouffe d'avant c'est pas mal
ça lui petit oiseau sas pour faire des
flèches
tam est en fait arrivé sur l'île puis
finalement tu détruis absolument tout
quoi peut l'attraper ou pas oh non mais
là je peux l'atteindre avec mes mains
sont des connaît même le croquer tout de
suite à l'info s'est installé là bas on
va aller ailleurs
bahreïn est un petit peu le
l'emplacement en regarder ça aussi c'est
nouveau voilà maintenant l'armure que
j'obtiens grâce à la peau de lézard on
la voit sur mon bras on dirait pas comme
ça mais elle nous protège c'est un mec
il ya un mec annoncé un petit arbuste
mais ils sont fourbes un ils ressemblent
à des mecs de loin oya des ratons
laveurs c'est vrai une nouveau tome je
dis ça puisque tu comme un gros con il
est des ratons laveurs mais par contre
au but ça sert à rien de les dégommer
non c'est adorable surtout vidéo et
j'espère qu'on pourra en domestique et
un jour il nous défendra et où il battra
d'un jet d'encre on construira sa maison
car en fait finalement on sera un
esclave du [ __ ] laveur regarder il est
un peu gros quand même temps ils ont
bien mûri les indigènes
ok faisons ici ce sera parfait en rien
cailloux là haut up parfait celui qui ne
manquaient bon ma 9e
voilà attention tir à tourner avant il
me fait pas peur comme ça je veux pas
que tu passes dans le feu moi je les
prévenus on n'est pas responsable en cas
de brûlure de [ __ ] laveur alors
première nouveauté qui est génial une
maison à mettre dans les arbres voilà
alors on dirait pas comme ça mais revoir
oui alors là alors là à la revente ça va
valoir cher ça je vous le dis hop c'est
parti nous faut 35 bons à l'agefi qui a
coupé pendant huit années et demie à
dubois [ __ ] elle ou la cabane à west
ham ce que j'allais couper l'arbre dans
le cahier à la cabane
mon corps non surtout pas oh ça y est il
vient déjà et ainsi je n'attaque pas il
peut être gentil on peut vivre en
harmonie avec moi croient qu'il est
intéressé par cette maison à temps je
fais il a construit elle a ensuite on
voit pour un prix de revente d'accord
adore soit on a peur at a fait part d'un
arbre sur la tête et ces corps que je
peux devenir pote avec les indigènes et
qui m'aident à construire un truc là
alors ça ça à faire des sticks ou dvd
home abriteront ça c'est l'arbre à un
peu en adolescence quoi il est ni gros
ni fin tu sais pas trop ce qui va donner
aux mais il a fait peur ce con mais
attention où tu montes j'ai vu il que
voler comme ça au la nuit tombe
et ça tombe bien parce que la cabane est
prêtre prête parlons pas prêtre y as a
de la gueule je montre comment comme ça
oh on est bien un peu à l'étroit mais
bon on a une belle vue en vrai que fait
cet homme en l'air nous attendait mais
fait carrément peur quoi garder le bon
cet appartement va falloir très très
cher va pouvoir leur rendre compte au
moins 50 de buch [ __ ] il nous faut un
tour de magie règles pour nous quoi bien
le détail sur la paume des pieds et on
va faire sans plus tarder
la nouveauté qui m'attire le plus une
cage à la part c'est qu'à votre stylet
on va enfin pouvoir faire ce petit
élevage de lapins
j'en ai rêvé jour et nuit ah ah alors
faut jeter repart n'a pas avant toute
chose de moi je peux le faire des matchs
de [ __ ] laveur souhaitait encore plus
sympa hop je le prends et je mets là
dedans c'est à donner mais j'en ai
attrapé qu'un méchant et 28000 quoi donc
dans le regarder c'est n'importe quoi
ils sont là ils sont tous vision favre
élevage de l'apa et si je construis un
autre élevage de lapins est ce qu'on
vient le roi de leroy des lapins
attendait mais je crois que là j'ai tout
de manière illimitée il ya un box aux
plats et bien vous savez quoi
on va en profiter pour faire pas un pas
deux mais trois élevages de lapins
voilà on est les rois l'air ou année là
par watt
mais je voulais je vais mieux je peux
retourner car la part des arrêtés et ils
me otc [ __ ] de la peinture les uns
l'apa ou pas va-t-on le faut que je
retrouve et que je bute parce que là
j'aime pas moi je me sens observé là il
ya un peu de visas vis ça va pas du tout
ça ça va faire échouer la revente
d'autres terribles appartement bien
c'est mon appartement
c'est le mien c'est bon qu'est ce qu'il
ya
vient bien près du fleuve bon eh beh à
ce tournoi zoé arrête à temps mais c'est
son frère j'ai tué ton frère en quoi
elle ses fesses nues au poursuit il est
là il est là il nous coûte tourner il
est malin il grappillera pfff tu me
connais pas il va tomber avec l'abe
c'est moi qui vous le dis au calme et à
tort car vendanges pourquoi arrête avec
ton attaque sautée arrête opus n'a même
pas de kaman toit a laissé sa mère arrêt
dit dont tu redescends maintenant à ça
suffit si j'avais un arc la pile entre
les deux fêtes j'aurais mis la flèche
saute vas-y il est où il est où mais
c'est super j'en ai marre il est trop
impressionnant le soleil [ __ ] laveur
protéger moi mais regarde notre atout
majeur la tension mais je t'aimais je
t'avais dit fais attention au feu ça
sert à rien je peux pas déteindre vient
bien de quoi bien quoi viens avec moi tu
me suis viens viens mon dieu bien là
bien bien dans l'eau tu es ou non ne
dites pas qu'il est décédé
non pas qu'il est décédé [ __ ] je
t'avais dit pas marcher dans le feu
[ __ ] aux opus il me suivait une
tournée autour il voulait vraiment de
l'aide quoi mais diable ou juste là tu
vas payer pour ce que tu as fait tu ne
mérite pas d'être ici
la vengeance sera terrible qu'est ce qui
fait tout de suite tu veux être la
peinture on est ami avec des lapins
c'est ça j'ai besoin de ton âme mais
attention à ton labeur attention
[Musique]
non ok fabriquer plus torche ce mec qui
veut qui veut devenir un phare en fait
je vengerait [ __ ] c'est le [ __ ] laveur
qui brûle et alors ils vont tous périr
les uns après les autres
non moi le premier oui sous les
indigènes la haye avait du monde à quand
j'étais tout nu et je venais d'arriver
sur l'île par contre là quand j'ai une
belle armure est un vrai coq n'y a plus
personne à te voilà criminels saloperies
à tuer les autres passagers du vol mais
ça je m'en fous statuaire à tonton je
vais faire un réel attentats dans cette
grotte
montrez-vous barbares sans poils et sans
vêtements mais elle est déserte quoi
cette grotte [ __ ] merde on a fait bien
rien dans cette grotte c'était bien nul
comment ça vanne qui l'a pas vous avez
bien dodo comment ça va me suis [ __ ]
qui essaie toujours d'être pote avec des
lapins
non mais sans déconner depuis la
dernière vidéo il s'est passé un truc
lâchez pas ils ont vu des promos pour
partir en vacances sur une autre île et
l'ont jeté tout de suite les billets et
son parti quoi mais regardez ça c'est un
campement d'indigènes
il n'y a aucun indigènes r&d même les
lapins ont pris possession des lieux
quoi aux gens voient un abord loin il
fait son footing au bord de la plage
vide cui cui à les [ __ ] de lézard ok
on le mange seniors on s'en fout je fous
c'est bon la barre au salut on fait la
fête ou pas aller sous l'aisselle
cameron bon moi j'ai fait du de l'aïkido
j'ai fait des techniques spatiales
regarde jamais quel mal préparée ok moi
un mois ils arrivent ils arrivent ils
arrivent ils arrivent mais pourquoi il
n'arrive pas à tirer en bas il mange son
pote il est en train de manger sous
[ __ ] de potes
dino un c pour râteau a uniquement pour
lui
adios attends attends tu peux pas
décrire comme ça à ça fait du bien
hu sicaud pâte et voit les gens c'est
déjà fin de cette vidéo sur ce de forest
oil ça vous a plu
je suis très content voilà j'ai fait mes
élevage de lapins ma petite cabane dans
les bois cité une partie parfaite
finalement c'est à vous a plu n'hésitez
pas à vous faire un câlin à vous-même
voilà parce que vous êtes génial et plus
sortir très vite dans une nouvelle vidéo
chat ou le monde pis
[Musique]